I'm here and I get out of here and I
will there's gonna be carnage
I said you had to read lethal protector
and just can kind of see what we're
creating here and how we're developing
and bringing this to the screen lady
broch is in the brach report the lethal
protector but for all his good intention
he gets in his own way he has paid the
price for that and he's lost pretty much
everything that he cared about he's not
the greatest fundamental base for an
altruistic hero in any aspect if there's
a black and white world of a good of an
evil he is definitely great venom is
this incredible character with this
amazing history that goes all the way
back to the 1980s so there's a lot of
stories you know real wealth of ideas to
draw on he became the Wolverine of
spider-man villains instantly started
going right to the top you just slap him
on a cover people are gonna buy that
issue people loved the character
everybody is Charlie we have great news
about the venom sequel we have a teaser
to break down Andy Serkis is going to be
the director so I'll explain what's
going on with that he did an interview
explaining the story that they're doing
what they're gonna be changing and what
the movies gonna wind up looking like
because we're getting ready to start
production while I was making this video
to Sony announced that it's doing some
live action spider-man TV shows with
Lord and Miller who are the producers
from spider-man into the spider-verse so
I'll talk about that at the end of the
video too so we'll break it all down
we're doing that Avengers end game
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
best venom sequel theory on the video
some of what they're doing during the
venom sequel even gets into a little bit
of what they did with spider-man far
from home and how they change those
characters so we'll give a spoiler
warning when we need to talk about the
ending of spider-man far from home but I
just broke this down top-10 style so
number 10 big news the other day you
probably heard his Andy Serkis was
recently confirmed as the director of
the venom sequel right away people were
asking him what he was actually going to
do with the movie because he's a very
different type of director than Ruben
Fleischer who directed the first movie
the reason why he left is because he was
doing the zombie land sequel and that
conflicted with the shooting dates for
the venom sequel no shade 2 that
director from the first movie but I am
so happy that they got Andy Serkis so
much of this movie is motion capture
performance because of the way the Venom
symbiote works in the way they shoot the
movies in Andy Serkis is probably the
most famous motion capture artist and
actor
alive right now nine everyone remembers
him as Gollum from Lord of the Rings
movies he even does it on talk-show
still people will still ask him to do
the Gollum voice but he also did some
amazing motion capture work in the
Planet of the Apes movies as Caesar you
probably even realized that Woody
Harrelson who is playing the carnage
character starred with Andy Serkis in
the most recent Planet of the Apes film
so they've already worked together
before this yes of course he also does a
lot of regular ngon motion capture
acting in big films he was great as
ulysses klaw and black panther and
Avengers age of Ultron but just to give
you an idea of what a big deal he is in
Hollywood Studios on other movies that
use a lot of motion capture we'll bring
him in to advise and help with the
actors who may not necessarily be
experienced in doing that kind of motion
capture performance so not only he's the
most sought-after person by all
Hollywood Studios 8 he's also been
trying to get more work as a full-time
director himself so this is a huge win
for the venom sequel Sony and a huge win
for Andy Serkis himself 7 right after
they confirmed him as the director he
revealed that they're using Marvel's
lethal protector comic as the core of
their story for the sequel and then
obviously all the added character beats
from the carnage introduction in the
comics he did an interview a little
while after that and because of what he
said during that we know a little bit
about how they're going to change the
story so 6 he's already started work on
pre-production in the movie it's
supposed to start shooting this fall
this is what he said and I'm just
quoting him here I'm right in the
beginning stages so I got some very
clear ideas about the journey and what
I'd like to see visually in how we can
take the characters into another
direction Tom Hardy was very involved in
the writing with screenwriter Kelly
Marcel of the new story so it's very
much centered around their take 5 you're
asking what does that mean
taking the characters in a new direction
Tom Hardy making some story and
character choices that sound like there
different from what they did with the
characters in the first film really it
just means that in adapting the lethal
protector in carnage stories they'll be
focusing a little more on developing the
characters than they did in the first
movie because typically with big
tentpole movies like this you already
know what the big major action scenes
are going to be and then a lot of what
changes during production is the actual
connective tissue in a lot of the
dialogue between the characters there
was a bit of a conspiracy during the
making of the first venom movie you may
have heard about Sony initially started
developing venom as a rated R movie
pitch after the success of the Deadpool
movie at Fox so it makes sense Sony
controls the venom character you have a
hardcore darker character like that it's
very easy to make him rated R and still
be very true to Marvel comic book
stories but then this conspiracy theory
went on that when they actually started
production so much time had gone by
actual times that Sony's film studio was
under performing spider-man movies
always do great but all the rest of
Sony's movies were dragging down on
their profits so the studio made the
choice to go pg-13 with venom to appeal
to a wider audience and potential bigger
box office take the gamble as we all saw
paid off
venom did over 850 million dollars at
the box office but by changing from a
darker rated-r venom movie to pg-13
while they were in the middle of
shooting the movie caused all kinds of
problems for when you go back and you
watch the venom movie now notice how Tom
Hardy's performance which amazing as it
is Tom Hardy is fantastic seems very out
of tone with what a lot of the other
actors are doing in their scenes a lot
of that is because of the stuff they
changed mid shoot in addition to
allowing Tom Hardy to do just whatever
he wanted most of that Eddie Brock
performance came all from Tom Hardy they
sort of treated him the way that the
Marvel movies treat Robert Downey jr.
you give him a script to go off of but a
lot of what he winds up doing is
improvisation just because it's such a
fantastic actor so that's why you have
people like Michelle Williams who's an
amazing actress seeming like her
character is part of a darker more
serious movie with the way she's
performing and then all of a sudden Tom
Hardy's Eddie Brock just jumps in a
lobster tank all that is pure Tom Hardy
choices he's making in the moment all
the Tom Hardy stuff is great it's just
that you
to plan on that from the start and build
all the supporting characters
performances around that so when Andy
Serkis says the Tom Hardy was involved
in the story process of the sequel movie
and they got lots of ideas for taking
the characters in a new direction and
making the story more relevant to
current events that just means that
they're going in a more Tom Hardy
direction with all the characters not
just the venom character himself as far
as making the story more relevant to
current events that's a lot of what they
did with spider-man far from home with
the Mysterio character in the big twist
of the ending so I'll say quick spoiler
warning for spider-man far from home
because we need to talk about the ending
of that movie during that movie Mysterio
as a villain uses fake news in the magic
of editing as his main weapons he's an
actor crafting his own movie within a
movie which I thought was pretty clever
that movie is the story of how he'd
Mysterio is the world's greatest super
hero and the villain of that movie is
Peter Parker's spider-man the main
villain of the venom sequel is carnage
he's a very very disturbed self-centered
Eagle maniacal character his way is the
only way and his way is the way of pain
and suffering the more recent comics
like absolute carnage which is a huge
spider-man crossover event take this
idea to the nth degree the carnage
character going on his own little
crusade to talk to God he gets stuck on
this idea and he's given this terrible
power to see his vision come to reality
that's the whole idea what would happen
if a crazy person got godlike powers we
just had Santos with the Infinity
Gauntlet he might be a little bit crazy
but you still know where he is coming
from there's a logic to the way he
thinks there is almost no logic to the
way that carnage thinks he's completely
unpredictable and that's why it's so
hard to fight him 3 talking about
release date the movie is supposed to
come out October 2020 next year right
now they're still on schedule to hit
that date unless something changes while
they're shooting or they run into big
problems next year while they're editing
the movie I'd expect to see the first
teaser trailer or any kind of footage
around the time they released the birds
of prey movie in February because that's
around the time where we saw the first
teaser for the original venom movie the
Morbius living vampire movie is coming
out at the end of July next year that's
within the venom versus considered a
venom spit off so I'm expecting a teaser
around February for that to eventually
if they can get their other spin-offs
like silk or the Craven movie or any
sinister six movies off the ground that
we probably get to a point where you see
like two spider-man's spin-off movies
every single year or every other year
outside of the Tom Hollands spider-man
movies as far as those live-action Lord
and Miller spider-man spin-off TV series
I'm guessing it'll be some of the lesser
characters I don't know what they're
allowed to do in terms of Peter Parker
on live-action TV because it has been a
hot minute since we've had a live-action
Peter Parker spider-man on TV but if we
get any more details about those I will
totally make videos - as far as they
said Woody Harrelson is still playing
carnage but they won't confirm that till
right before they start shooting I'm
okay if they want to recast they recast
warmachine between Iron Man 1 and Iron
Man 2 and no one really cared that much
I was not a fan of the red wig that they
put on Woody Harrelson I will totally be
okay if they get rid of that wig
Michelle Williams is going to be coming
back as Eddie Brock's girlfriend maybe a
little bit more she venom action and
they haven't announced which other big
main comic book characters that they're
going to do but the script is finished
so they already know what the story is
going to be in fact I'm actually kind of
hoping now because of absolute carnage
that they call the venom sequel maximum
carnage and then just call venom 3
whatever that movie winds up being
absolute carnage in number one asked for
spider-man Tom Holland involvement based
on Kevin Feige recent comments around
Comic Con in the conspiracy surrounding
the Marvel and Sony sharing arrangement
for that character I don't think that
Tom Holland is going to cross over right
now but Kevin Feige did confirmed that
Sony does plan to eventually cross Tom
Hollands spider-man over with venom but
that movie would be pure Sony and he
Kevin Feige wouldn't have anything to do
with it meaning that right now venom
still has nothing to do with the MCU
they're treating him like he's in
another universe but as you probably
suspected because Marvel phase four is
trading so hard on the idea of the
multiverse spider-verse
is a really easy way to explain how MCU
spider-man can crossover with venom in
venom can still be its own separate
thing that the MCU movies don't really
have to deal with everyone post your
theories about the venom sequel in the
comments below and if you have any big
questions about it I'll try to answer
them in the comments but I have my
spider-man far from home
leda's scenes video that I'm still
working on I have more Marvel phase four
videos while you wait for all that stuff
click here to learn about what's going
on with spider-man 3 at Marvel and click
here for my Deadpool 3 teaser video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you